what holds us back from better embracing
change might not be what you think and I
think it's two things the first thing is
mindset and what we always find with
leaders is we can't tell them that
they're the ones that are holding us
back from change we have to show them
and the reason why I think mindset is
what holds us back is we don't realize
how much we resist change on an on a
regular basis in fact one of the things
I talk about a lot with people is that I
don't think that we're grooming leaders
right now I think that we are grooming
professional skeptics a lot of people
are they are becoming risk-averse
because so much is on the line they are
skeptical because the unknown is
obviously more frightening than the
known and you can ask people when you
give them new ideas what they think
about that idea and most times nine
times out of ten people's reaction will
be able to tell you what they don't like
about the idea first before they can
tell you what they like so shifting the
mindset to seeing possibilities right
what could happen versus what's wrong
with something keeps an idea alive and
that's very important in terms of
getting people in the mindset for change
don't shut something down before you
give it a fair chance the second thing
that I think holds us back is our
assumptions and I talked a lot about
this in my book kill the company is that
we have a lot of assumptions around how
things should work have always work need
to work we've always tried things that
way and I think one of the problems is
our assumptions hold us back from
actually attacking problems and what I
mean by this is often we look at
problems as very big very large and
that's because we have a lot of
assumptions about that problem and we
teach people how to break down a problem
into truths or many assumptions and
attack those individual assumptions and
turn them on their head if you can
actually take your assumptions and
change them you can start to see again
more possibilities for change we did a
case study with several companies but
one primarily down on Wall Street and
what was interesting about it is we work
together to come up with a new way to
instill change in an organization you
know most companies when they first of
all when they hear about a change
program now they they just want to turn
off right everyone has changed fatigue
the reason for that is most change
initiatives simply don't work and we
wanted to go about it in a new way so we
tested all kinds of things from tools
that were amazing to techniques that
were horrible and failed but what came
out of a research that we did with
several companies over many years but
one intently over eight weeks was this
change cannot be put on people the best
way to instill change is to do it with
them create it with them the second
thing is is that change of course has to
be supported from the top down it must
be supported from the top down but where
change happens is from the middle out so
the people that are sitting in what what
you do every day which is meetings and
emails the people that are doing those
things every day more than they'd like
those are the ones that are going to be
creating the change they're the ones
that have to be in power to do it
the third thing is is that I don't think
it should be a 12-step program people
are beyond tired of 12-step programs
they need a toolkit an undemanding kit
of tools that they can use when they're
stressed out when something happens
suddenly when they just don't know what
else to do the final thing is change
can't be complex no more complexity we
have to work on simplifying so it from
my perspective and at my company if
there's a tool that we have that takes
us more than an hour to teach you we
should be fired we should only give you
simple tools that every layer of the
organization can use and get on the same
page with change
you